i mean we've decided that even though
there are some difficulties like that
that our love is stronger than that
[Music]
i am 26 and i'm 63 just turned 63.
we've met on tinder i just set it up
from
18 to 100 or whatever the maximum age is
because i thought you never know you
know there might be someone who is a bit
older a bit younger that
might be my soulmate you know you just i
didn't want to like
cut anyone out because of age and then i
ended up meeting eileen
who's on this a little bit older
we talked after a couple of weeks about
well let's why don't we meet
i had injured my knee so i wasn't really
that mobile
i said to julia listen never do this
with anyone else
and you're welcome to not do it with me
but
what do you think about just coming by
my place you know what i mean i have
some prosecco we can order pizza
yeah so it happened i opened my door and
this
sublimely gorgeous smile made me it was
really really lovely i'll never forget
it
i remember coming up the stairs and
eileen opened the door and immediately i
just felt
so comfortable and lovely and i remember
we hugged
straight away yeah yeah and eileen is
such a gentle person
that she just made me feel so you know
just free and comfortable and welcome
as soon as i walked in and uh so sweet
yeah you were just so sweet and gentle
for the whole time i just felt so good
and
i'm usually quite shy when i first meet
people
yeah but i didn't feel shy with you
everything about you that night i
remember
just being very comfortable and i
admitted to you i was a little nervous
and you said i'm a little nervous too
and you know it was just really lovely
yeah did you kiss on that first date
but we just kissed yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah that's right as we got to know each
other
more intimately it was just
beautiful and wonderful in in every way
and uh you know so romantic as well yeah
just
really really romantic yeah we had a
very deep connection
yeah yeah we really did yeah it was just
magical we were so able to
to meet in a place romantically and
sexually and
you know in terms of love that is
i can only hope most people can visit
that do you know what i mean
and have that too what was the initial
reaction people had to finding out you
were dating
such a different age my family was
always
very very open with me being in an age
gap relationship
i remember telling my mom about ailing
even
before we met in person oh yeah because
we are like besties and i
tell her all my business
and she was completely like open and
fine with it
and so was the rest of my family and i
think they're pretty used to
me doing like unusual things like yeah
so they weren't like that surprised or
anything didn't think it was that big of
a deal
the only issues we've had have been
online i am a youtuber i do that
full-time and as soon as eileen and i
started getting a little bit more
serious in our relationship
we decided to do a few videos together
we ended up getting a few viral videos
that got a few million views and stuff
so we did get you know some hate because
we are a very unusual couple yeah yeah
so some people
were very shocked or thought it was
weird and
yeah you know or got offended in some
way by us being
together yeah right yeah it's silly
because we're not hurting anyone
you know we're just loving each other
i've been called a go digger online a
bunch of times just because i'm younger
and that comment really really upsets me
because i've worked so hard to have
everything i have
and if you don't mind me staying there
please please i do
you know earn more yeah you out earn
money there's no question
and it just makes me so upset like when
people
say things like that yeah what are you
doing is there any comment that sticks
in your head
well well pedophile is the one
it's just so awful because i mean i'm
you know i'm younger but i'm 26
we are both consenting adults and there
is
a really huge difference yeah yeah you
know i see age gap couples like male
female whether males like my age and the
females like julia's age and i think
do they have commonality and then i
think eileen chill
you know you're with someone who's you
know you know what i mean like you have
to search your own
reactions all of us have preconceived
notions of what's what and we
i think it's just really important to
ask oneself questions about
impulsive reactions and to not go
forward on them you know
sometimes when we go out people do think
you're my mom
yeah yeah yeah i mean not not in a bad
way
is that your daughter yeah yeah yeah
they don't mean yeah just innocently
yeah yeah yeah
and uh we don't really mind anymore
right it's just
yeah and people just don't know it's
just kind of funny it's like
yeah yeah and we try to always like
introduce each other like as soon as we
meet someone
yeah that doesn't happen like that's my
life like julia
you know who asked who to marry i
proposed to her
one of my gigs so i asked her to come up
on stage yeah
and she thought i was gonna make her
sing or something embarrassing
and then i proposed and then i later
uh when we went to brazil for a month uh
on the beach i
because i didn't want julia not to you
know be proposed to
and i didn't want her not to have a ring
so i got an engagement ring and we were
on the beach and
at night and in brazil i think in rio
was it
and uh i proposed to julia it was really
really beautiful
why do you think there was such a taboo
around age gap daily
i think especially because we are
two women who are in an age gap
relationship people have
a hard time accepting it because they
see older women
only as mothers or grandmothers they
don't see them
as individuals and as sexual beings as
well
so to think that an older woman could be
interested in someone younger and having
fun
and being sexual it kind of offends
people
somehow i feel like people are a little
bit more comfortable
with seeing an older man with a younger
woman because
they don't see older men the same way
they see older women
that's a really good point so for you
guys in terms of like children
how are those discussions when we're
planning and thinking about the future
because i mean knock on wood but
if things go as they naturally would
i would probably outlive
i mean yeah yeah and that as sad as it
is
it's you know something that we had to
talk about before getting married and
everything
yeah and you know it's hard and there
are certain things that
we think about like having children we
would love to have children together
but you know we'll have to see how it
goes because
um you know that's an area that
our age difference yeah yeah i mean
we've decided that
even though there are some difficulties
like that
that our love is stronger than that
and yeah we decided that
you know we just didn't want to not be
together
yeah yeah
[Music]
so the stunt coordinator was going to
fire the air ram so it had a lead with
the button going to him offset
when he does fire the button i'm
virtually in line with the ground so he
fires the air ram which fires me
straight onto the back of my neck
and literally i'm lying on the floor and
i can't feel my legs
and this went on for about two minutes
it's the worst feeling in the world you
know i thought i was paralyzed could not
feel my legs at all
thought i broke up my neck